foreign
what are you doing I don't know man we
always get the [__] camera angle is
always [__] with me well that's it
well you're not here like early enough
to get in the shot is that what it is
yeah okay if you were here early enough
to get in the shots
well yeah I was gonna come get you
[Laughter]
weren't yeah I was watching I was
watching YouTube yeah you're just
watching some [__] on YouTube
meanwhile like I'm like uh it's less
than two minutes are you coming or what
or you know what I mean I even had to
fix ma'am drink okay damn
lost track of time yeah you do that I
lost track of time you do that
so yeah we're talking about uh Zach's
Tom looks farther back today y'all look
like a Pet Shop Boys music yeah yeah
there's something about this damn
shot I keep having to come further out
this way I don't I don't really
understand so you need like next to her
I used to be able to sit next to her and
still be in shop but if I saw it next to
her right now I wouldn't be in in frame
well that's because you got all that
[__] over there and you know if I sat
there you wouldn't see me see well now
you can't if you pull up if my head was
here look farther my head was right here
next to you look where it would be see
well the camera's closer too because
it's not yeah that's what it is because
the camera's closer yeah because we got
rid of the um yeah what you call it it's
a close tripod yeah it's closer by about
six inches yeah so that's all it is and
I can't really push this back anymore
because there's a bunch of crap behind
there so you know what I mean yeah wide
angle lens yeah maybe I don't know I
don't think we need it he's just he's
just complaining you got plenty of room
I just got to be sitting in a different
new spot you got plenty of room back
yeah
but yeah uh yeah murder Hornet season
usually a little Tom explaining uh
little avatars that I made I still love
them I'm explaining yeah although you
haven't Tom explained anything yet no
but you know
the show's still still in its early
stages so I'm sure yeah that that will
happen it may it may oh it will it's a
certainty yeah we're gonna doing a
haunting episode this one was a pretty
good one I like this one season seven
episode
five yeah
ashes of evil not asses of evil that's
the porn version yeah yeah
[Laughter]
not and not my ass is haunted yeah it's
an actual porn movie that's Belladonna
isn't it yeah I think so yeah it is yeah
but uh but yes this is ashes of evil and
it's actually kind of not funny because
the ashes represent
um although the title ashes of evil even
though this does kind of have something
to do with the [__] that happened in the
actual story like there was a fire that
killed people and they thought that that
was what the what the you know who the
ghosts were but they're implying that
the people that were killed in the fire
were the ones doing the evil but that's
not how it turned out as it happened
yeah like they don't know that for sure
it's because it's ghost [__] they just
they just saw paranormal [__] they just
thought yeah even being attacked by
Shadows
it's like dark figures
yeah pretty much well there was other
[__] too there was actually like a
couple things in here that um that I
thought were actually kind of
interesting yeah which we'll kind of get
into in a little bit but as I mentioned
before as these are going on like as we
get later and later in the seasons of a
haunting like my notes actually get
shorter and shorter because so much of
the episodes now are recap yeah filler
like they have to you know they they do
like four minutes of story and then they
do like a commercial break which we
don't watch obviously because we have
the DVDs but um then when it comes back
then they have to do like a minute or
two of recap of [__] we just saw yeah or
they recap stuff that happened like at
the beginning of the episode I'm like so
which in a way kind of makes it easier
because I'm like well at least I don't
have to write it down again because I
already wrote it down but yeah so
because remember
when we used to do the earlier haunting
episodes sometimes I'd have like five
six seven pages of notes now I have like
a page front and back and then a front
and then that's it
you know what I mean because that's like
all that happened the rest of it was
just fillers that just goes to show how
much of the time it's taken up with
not you know the story not being like
all that well so that kind of that kind
of checks out though because you know
most like Paranormal incidences there's
not a lot there it's just a couple
things that happen right the rest of it
is like I think it was this I think it
was that I just saw this Shadow
something touched me something grabbed
me you know some [__] like that
something so pinched my ass yeah asses
of evil yeah yeah woke up and the condom
was on me already
I feel like something's gonna jump on me
oh [__]
I felt the heat comes down
what did you do if you woke up and you
had a condom on your one right yeah yeah
that was if you were already erect ready
to go man this is supposed to be a
paranormal
confused yeah we're getting confused
what show this is
because we were on streamate last night
so it's like there's got to be some
there's gonna be some carryover I guess
but uh but yeah yeah we did a little
while no it's not long I think we're
just on there yeah
it was actually pretty cool because I
was trying to have permission to mention
his name no I'm not gonna say who it is
like um they said that they were gonna
come by and like watch the show but they
were all up on the show like they knew
all the stuff about the like all the
stuff just about Xi'an and stuff like
that yeah
um and they had seen like the movie
review that we just did in the last
episode and everything like that so I
thought it was kind of cool because you
you know we had somebody that like we
could actually talk to because a lot of
people that come in the room you know
they just kind of yeah want particularly
yeah he already had all your videos and
everything right yeah yeah he didn't
vote
[__] bought it bought a nice long
show with us he we had a good time yeah
yeah it was really fun yeah I'm glad
that I'm glad that he came by so I don't
know if he's listening to see if he said
he was lurker I didn't comment all that
much I do remember that screen name
though like
but yeah so I just wanted to like give
him a shout out because yeah he came by
and hung out on stream eight with us
last night and that was like super fun
yeah but yeah uh so do you want to talk
about ashes of evil go ahead not asses
evil yeah
that'll be that'll be a different show
yeah so this happened in uh uh 2011
October 2011.
in a little bitty town called Hampton
Tennessee somewhere near Appalachian
Trail yeah
so um according to the couple at the
center of this this is a very very small
town very out in the country kind of out
in the middle of nowhere so the couple
at the center of this their names are
Calvin and Amelia I had to look up their
last name because I said are they saying
bratty like like a bratty child or is it
Bradley Bradley no it was actually
bratty but it's b-r-a-d-d-y like I
looked it up yeah because I was like it
sounds like they're saying bratty I
wrote down br80 d-d-i-e but then Tom
said maybe it's Bradley and I'm like
yeah I don't know because like I said we
don't have the
yeah because that because [__] the death
apparently they don't come with captions
yeah yeah that's what I mean I don't
understand it because like everything
comes with captions nowadays even and
now they have like AI generated ones
because now every YouTube video has
they're not great but they're you know
workable
so yeah so this is Calvin and Amelia
they have uh two kids they have a
five-year-old daughter named Sarah and a
one-year-old daughter like a baby named
Chelsea
so they don't buy this house they're
actually like renting it it was a house
that was kind of big and it was built in
the 1800s and they actually they didn't
mention this at first but I guess they
were renting an apartment like on the
second floor I don't know how many
apartments this house had been converted
into
because they were the only ones that got
shown so I'm assuming they had the whole
second floor that's kind of how they
made it look but it doesn't really
matter
so Calvin they said worked as um like a
maintenance guy and Amelia was a
stay-at-home mom
so this was like a fairly big apartment
it was three bedrooms
um the one on the reenactment was
obviously probably much nicer than the
one in real life because that's what
they usually do but they said yeah it
was kind of like the perfect place
except because it was on the second
floor it had this kind of um like a wrap
around porch like I had one on the
bottom floor and then I had one on the
top floor and they said that you know
they have little kids and if the little
kids like wander out onto the porch
obviously you can fall over the railing
and die you know what I mean
so uh so Amelia's a little bit nervous
about that but whoever lived in the
house before or converted it or whatever
um obviously thought of that because the
doors it looked like French doors that
were leading out from the house like out
onto the porch had a lock down here and
then also a lock way up on the top and
you had to like do both of them and they
were like and they felt better because
there's no way the kids could reach
those and remember that for later
because that's kind of like an important
detail so they're like yeah so if we
keep both the doors locked then the kids
can't get out and everything's fine
so Amelia said pretty much from when
they moved in
she said It felt
um very heavy she said it felt like
someone didn't want them there and
another thing that she said that I
thought was kind of interesting was she
said it felt like we had moved in on top
of someone that's what she said I so I I
kind of liked that like there were some
wording like there was somebody already
there and they were like imposing on
this person so that was like yeah so you
said that's kind of what it felt like
yeah that house happens and me and my
buddy buddy were in after the Army was
like that
felt like that yeah like there was
already somebody else and they didn't
want you there yeah right you know what
I mean yeah bad house
so um so one day like a few days after
moving in I guess she's like in the
kitchen like cutting up apples or
something like that the kids are taking
a nap and she starts hearing like
creaking and footsteps like somebody
walking around and like banging like
somebody's in the house you know what I
mean so she goes and looks and obviously
nobody is there so that kind of creeps
her out a little bit but she's like oh
well whatever you know they always kind
of write it off at the beginning
and then
um several more days
um they have wait a minute oh she said
over the next few days they felt like
again like they weren't alone like there
was maybe somebody else in there with
them
so she's in the nursery this is pretty
alarming like you'd be pretty alarming
if this alarmed if this happened so
she's in the nursery like putting the
baby down like I said she had a
one-year-old putting the baby in the
crib
and I guess the little girl and the dad
were like out in the kitchen or whatever
so Amelia's in there putting the baby in
the crib and she said she heard a little
child's voice say Mommy
and then she said she felt a tug like on
her shirt like a little kid tugging her
shirt
so obviously she thinks it's her
daughter who's five uh and she's like
yeah what do you want but then when she
looks there's nobody there
and then when she goes out into the
kitchen like Sarah's been there with her
dad the whole time so she's like but I
know I heard a little kid's voice say
mommy like a couple of times and felt
something tug on her shirt like a little
kid would do
so that kind of weirds her out a little
bit
so basically then they have I don't
really know if this was anything because
I I don't think anybody said they saw
this because they showed the baby
sleeping in the crib
and then they also kind of show like
[__] moving around in the room like the
rocking chair like going by itself and
the mobile like over the crib like going
by itself and stuff like that but I
don't think I don't recall anybody
saying that they saw that so they might
have just added that for like creepy
effect or whatever
so they're all in the in the kitchen
and then all of a sudden like Sarah the
little girl like kind of wanders off
down the hall and she's standing there
in the hall looking into the nursery
and Amelia's like where the hell did
that kid go and she runs down the hall
and they see all of this smoke coming
out of the nursery and they're like holy
[__] like the [__] Nursery is on fire
right and the baby's in there so at
first because I remembered this episode
kinda but at first I thought because
wasn't there an episode where they
thought that like the house was on fire
but then it turned out it wasn't yeah so
I think that I confused us with this
because I was thinking oh you know it's
not really on fire even though obviously
the little girl saw it and then Amelia
saw it but no that the room really was
on fire
well um Haunting in Florida he kept um
Ed kept smelling cigar smoke maybe
that's what you're thinking of he
thought something was bartering in there
no it was definitely another episode
where where they went in the room and
they're like oh my God it's on fire but
then like it wasn't
but this one it wasn't like a huge fire
or anything but Amelia said when they
ran down the rim because she obviously
like screamed for Calvin it was like
holy [__] like the nursery's on fire so
they ran down there and Calvin was
actually able to put it out they called
the fire department anyway just in case
but um it turned out that the space it
looked like a space heater like
baseboard heater type thing
um that was in the nursery was like torn
out of the wall they said and there was
like Sparks and [__] coming out of it
and they're like and there's no way that
that could have happened because there's
like the only person that had been there
was the baby and the five-year-old and
they're like there's no way that a
five-year-old could tear a [__]
heater out the wall
so that was a little weird and they were
kind of freaking out about that but like
I said luckily nobody got hurt they got
the fire put out uh and everything
but then when the fire department shows
up
um one of the firefighters
she's in the nursery and they're like
okay it's all fine like the fire's out
and everything like that and then she
looks kind of troubled
and so Amelia kind of asks her like hey
like What's your deal like you know why
why do you look like that or whatever
and like the woman is like well did
anybody tell you about what happened in
here
and Amelia's like no we didn't know
anything about what happened in here
so the firefighter says oh um about 10
years ago there was a mom and her three
kids she was like a single mom and they
were living in this apartment and the
mom like fell asleep with a cigarette in
her hand and caught the apartment on
fire and all of them died
um including like they said they found
two kids dead in the bedroom and one of
them like in the closet and then the mom
was obviously dead too so like burned up
so
um you know as you can imagine that's a
little bit of an upsetting thing to hear
about the house that you're living in
and especially like in the room that
your baby is sleeping in
so Amelia said yeah she was really
really bothered by it and she really
didn't feel right about it because it
just felt really creepy and weird
after that she passes by Sarah's room
and notices that Sarah is talking to
somebody as though she's talking to
somebody like across from her like in
the room and she's like and at first
still it could happen more than once and
she wasn't like super concerned about it
because you know she's five you know
they have a imaginary friends and [__]
like that
but she's like so she's listening to
this kid talking and at first it seems
like fine like hey I have a doll you
want to play with it and blah blah but
then like after a few minutes the kid
starts getting upset like she's arguing
with the other person
um and basically says
um tells this imaginary friend to go
away
and then she looks up at her mom who's
like standing in the doorway and she's
like tell the kids to leave me alone
and Mom's like what kids are you talking
about and then Sarah says like one of
the creepiest things ever like did a kid
can say to you the kids that come out of
the closet yeah like you would say
you're fancy your [__] kids that kids
say creepy [__] like that all the time
though the kids that came out of the
closet tell them to leave me alone yeah
but yeah
you never know what to have little kids
coming out of the closet like Narnia
yeah it's like it's Peter and Lucy and
Susan and Edmond yeah they got some
[__] Turkish delight it's all it's
all a thing but uh but yeah coming out
of the closet oh my God we've been gone
for like 20 years I can't remember like
how how long were they in the wardrobe I
don't know in Lion The Witch in order in
the first one since I was a little kid
it was a long time because they grew up
because they were adults in Narnia but
then when they came back through the
Wardrobe they were kids again so they
lived like a long time like a whole
entire lifetime
that was I really liked that book but I
didn't I didn't really care for the
other ones but I liked that one a lot
because they get more like christiany
like as they go on you know what I mean
I mean the first one's kind of
Christianity too but it's not not as
overt
but um but yeah
so Amelia is starting to think well
obviously you know the Sarah is talking
about like kids talking to you wearing
bloody black coming out of her closet
she's like well these must be the ghosts
of the three kids that died in the fire
I mean it stands to reason right so
everything makes sense now and Amelia
says that she had actually always
believed in ghosts in the Paranormal so
this wasn't like a huge stretch for her
to be like okay well I guess it's just
these ghosts
so later on that night Amelia tells
Calvin about the whole ghost situation
but of course as with 99 of the dudes on
this show
um Calvin does not believe her and
basically is like you tripping so
there's that
then the next day
I will say that Calvin's disbelief lasts
um much less Long than uh most of the
dudes disappointed fire does because
literally like a scene or two later
like Calvin comes home from work and
Amelia and the kids aren't home like she
went to grocery stores and [__] like
that
Calvin comes home he's in the kitchen
and he hears like creaking behind him
and he turns around and sees a big
[__] Shadow dude you know what I mean
like a big man figure like like that and
uh he's basically uh screams his [__]
head off as you would as you would and
he didn't actually describe it though
they just showed you something yeah I
think it was just kind of a she
described it I think later on she was I
think black mist right yeah she said
something like she said it was like a
black mist but like solid like in a man
form
so I'm assuming because she said that he
saw the same thing so I'm assuming that
that's what he saw that's right like
they might have made it look a lot
scarier than it was in real life because
you know the one on the show like in the
reenactment it was just like growing
like really big like it was like
towering over the dude yeah what
wouldn't be impressed if it was just
something standing there
yeah I mean it'd still be scary but
you'd be like yeah okay yeah
you know what I mean it's Gotta Be You
Know if it's on if it's on screen it's
got to be uh something romantic
yeah you always got to be careful when
you watch these haunting episodes they
they add to the testimony yeah
they embellished that's right but like I
said they're trying to make an
entertaining show I mean if it was
boring people would [__] about that so
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna like yeah
because all of this could be made up for
all it could be you so I'm just saying
so yeah so he sees this big [__]
shadow figure screams his [__] hat
off and he's like cowering under it but
then it just like disappears
so as I mentioned so now Calvin's like
well I'll be damned I guess the
Paranormal exists after all uh should
have believed Amelia but like I said it
was only like a day or two that he had
that old disbelief thing going on
um however he said that he didn't tell
Emilia about him seeing this because she
was already kind of freaking out and
didn't want to like scare her anymore
because he said what he saw was like
really really scary
so then several nights after that
they're sleeping and the good old covers
start pulling off again this ghost love
to [__] do that man they just like
we're gonna give you pneumonia we're
just gonna pull the [__] blankets off
like that jerks so yeah so they started
doing that
and then the shadow guy apparently is
kind of hovering over Calvin and he
wakes up and sees it like sees its
non-face like hanging over his face
and he starts freaking out and then it
kind of seemed like it was strangling
him or sitting on his chest or something
like because he said that he couldn't
breathe and he couldn't talk and he was
like just laying there kind of choking
like it was
doing that
um and I think Amelia said that too
because she woke up in the middle and
said that he couldn't breathe or talk
and it was like it was really scary I
don't think she said that she saw the
black figure hovering over him though
but I guess he saw it
so at this point he's like okay well I
believe you now that the house is
haunted however I don't think that this
is them ghost kids that we were talking
about doing this [__] because this is
like some [__] scary [__] and I don't
think like little kids that died in a
fire would be like trying to strangle me
or nothing so he's like so there must be
some other situation going on here
so uh you know obviously they're kind of
all stressed out at this point
they feel kind of like trapped in the
house obviously they can't afford to
move and they feel very powerless
because they can't really do anything
about it
uh soon after this and
see this is what this is our minds are
in the gutter because
and well they walked right into this one
the wording that they used so like so I
guess the dad and the kids have like
gone out gone out and the narrator whose
name is Anthony call by the way
um very famous uh voice that he has for
this show
but Amelia is gonna have some alone time
yeah in the shower and I was like did
you just say that she was gonna have a
load that they said that on the show and
I'm like are you implying what I think
she's breaking toys in there and
everything like leave the woman alone
everybody needs them alone time that's
what he said yeah
[Laughter]
better bring your phone with you that's
what I mean I like do they really have
to word it that way because it sounded
so it sounded so yeah
that's usually like a euphemism well I
need some alone time you know what I
mean that's probably what they were
talking about I'm that well that's what
I mean and it's just like I don't know
if like maybe she said that maybe she
told him yeah I was gonna go in there
and rub one out the [__] Ghost came
after me I'm gonna call that alone time
I'm pretty sure that everybody knows
that thank you for pissing me so it's
like so I just thought I was in there
with a towel and [__] that's what I mean
even the way that they shot it like kind
of implied that she's gonna be like oh
you know yeah yeah gotta get away from
these kids right
I'm gonna I'm gonna love me yeah right
so I don't know I just thought that was
like really funny the puppy's away yeah
everybody was out of the house so she's
gonna go take a shower and I'm surprised
they didn't have his legs it was setting
up like candles and like rose petals and
[__] like that that would have been even
more over their feet up on a wall
a little glass of wine there yeah you
know
got some got some got some I got some
erotica like a waterproof erotica book
and yeah
something like that I'm just like I'm
not laughing at her I'm laughing at the
wording that they used because I was
like I hoped that they meant to apply
that because that's definitely with ANT
blood yeah
yeah so um so she goes so she gets to
take a shower and have some alone time
and so here's another thing that bothers
me a lot about and I get that if you're
home by yourself you might not
necessarily for example like close and
lock the bathroom door like when you're
going to the bathroom or taking a shower
or whatever however I've always closed
the door even if I'm home by myself yeah
like and I thought most people did that
it's like courtesy right it's like well
somebody could come home or if somebody
broke in what if you you know what I
mean I don't know I just don't really
think about it it's weird to me to leave
the door open even if nobody's home yeah
I have done it but like but not usually
like usually I'm weirded out by like
leaving the door open it's just habit
yeah that's what I'm saying because I
would always close it so I was kind of
wondering
because she goes in to take a shower and
she leaves the bathroom door open and
I'm like that's weird but I don't know
maybe she thought oh well nobody else is
home so it's fine but she had to listen
for the kids yeah but I didn't think the
kids were home I thought they were home
okay oh unless they were sleeping I
think they were sleeping well in that
case okay well that's a different
situation because yeah if they got up or
like started crying or something yeah
you'd have to hear them so I get that
but it's like I've had I was under the
impression that the kids were not home
so I was just kind of like why the [__]
would you leave the door open that's
like really that's weird I don't know
maybe it's not weird maybe I'm weird I
don't really yeah you're [__] weird
well I mean I know that but it's like I
didn't know if I was weird about that
particular thing you know what I mean
I'm not real up on what was normal
behavior and what's not you know what I
mean yeah I don't really know what
normal behavior is so um
saying so she says the door open so it's
implied she didn't say this but what
they showed in the reenactment was it
sounded like she heard
like a breath or something you know what
I mean they're like yeah like it kind of
sounded like that
and then she gets out of the shower
after having her alone time and you know
the mirror is all fogged up and whatnot
and then the mirror says die on it which
yeah yeah rude
so I guess the Ghost came in there and
wrote die on the mirror yeah she said it
was like pretty clearly written in there
yeah which let's that's not nice
ghosts or jerks
so uh so yeah oh you know what I did
write down kids asleep they were asleep
yeah Calvin not wrapped up okay so okay
so it's not where the door is open I
apologize I didn't get down to that part
of my notes yet but uh but yeah
so from this point well now since this
[__] ghost is right in [__]
die on the mirror I mean that's a little
alarming right so they're like okay well
we're just all gonna sleep in the same
room so now they all sleep in the living
room and you know Calvin's like kind of
sitting up watching everybody's they
take like turns like watching everybody
make sure nothing bad happens
and then at this point so this is I
guess later the same night of the of the
die shower
um
so Calvin falls asleep and Amelia gets
up and goes into the kitchen to get a
glass of water and then they show like a
little ghost girl who I'm assuming is
one of the kids that died in the fire
although she didn't say that she saw
that but they do show the little girl
like pop up in the kitchen door and then
be like oh [__] and then like run away
like down the hall or something and then
implying that this other shadowy male
thing ghost entity whatever is chasing
after the ghost right so that they're
trying to like make that implication
that it's not the ghost doing all this
stuff it's this entity
so um so the little girl runs away and
then uh Amelia turns around and she sees
the big ass like shadow guy too like
like and he's all like in the corner
everything like that and again screams
her head off just like her husband did
like I said it's probably you would too
if you saw that [__] I mean I would I'm
not proud
so at this point this was kind of good
because this was another one where I
kind of like the ones where the church
doesn't get involved I guess because
there's so many of those and it gets
like really samey and it's just like
there's only so many times you can watch
a priest come over and do the exorcism
and all that kind of crap but um so they
actually just went right to calling a
paranormal group in nearby Jonesborough
Tennessee
and this guy I think his name's Bob
Phillips and he had
I put sticky uppy hair dude that's what
I called him like before they said what
his name was because remember how his
hair was like regular hair regular hair
but then there was like a little bit in
the middle that was just sticking
straight up like that yeah
and I was like
that's certainly a choice yeah
I think maybe not maybe he didn't know
it looked like that I don't really know
but it's just it didn't look like I was
like I was like look either lay it all
down or stick it all up I'm not I'm very
confused by the gym was confused by the
man's hair
and that was that was from from like the
two yeah but I mean I know that but it's
like I have something like it was
blowing but I remember people having
that hair but usually it looked more
deliberate is what I wanted to say it
didn't look deliberate it kind of looked
accidental like he just like like there
was some static electricity [__] going
on and nobody told him yeah it kind of
looked like that because it wasn't
enough to make it look like he did it on
purpose men's hair fads that goes in and
out real fast it was just really weird I
mean you know what I mean yeah you could
do the spiky hair like yeah you could be
like Guy Fieri or whatever and like have
all the [__] hair spike in it but at
least that's a deliberate choice I could
I couldn't tell with this so I was very
confused so I yeah I wrote down all this
kind of stuff about it because I was
just like why
so um I think his name was Bob Phillips
or Rob Phillips I can't read my own
handwriting Rob and Bob is about the
same yeah Robert bobber whatever yeah
um yeah so him and then there's another
woman that works with the Paranormal TMC
and her name was Kathy Shepard I think I
wrote that down
so they come later with their whole team
or whatever
now Kathy tells them that not only
to this mom and three kids die in this
fire like 10 years ago
but there was like bad [__] happening in
this house even way before that because
this house is really old
so they said like even in the 1920s this
house was a halfway house for male
prisoners and there was allegedly a
whole bunch of criminal activity going
on like especially like during
prohibition and stuff like that and they
also said that a dude at least one dude
had been shot and killed at the house
too so
you know that they're like okay so we
might have more Spirits going on here or
whatever
so the investigators are trying to make
contact with whoever these Spirits are
with the EVP [__]
now the team said that yeah definitely
the mom and the three kids are in here
because they got all of these several
voices on their EVP recordings even
though notably well I mean they never
play the recordings but they also didn't
say what any of the voices said
they just said oh yeah we got several
voices on the EVP recordings and then
that was kind of the end of it they just
shoot moved on so I imagine probably
they weren't that impressive because I
feel like if they were impressive they
would have said what they said and they
didn't
so while they're going around doing
their investigation
um Amelia's in the kitchen and she
apparently gets attacked like she
suddenly goes oh [__] you know what I
mean and like [__] get killed over
shouldn't kill over but you know what I
mean she kind of punches over
she said she felt like a burning
sensation on her back
and then they pull her shirt neck down
or whatever and she's got those Telltale
three scratch marks and you know what
that means that means the Unholy Trinity
it's a demon yeah and they even had to
say that on this because they say that
in every [__] yeah just like that
after the war just like they have to
Define EVP like on every single life
even I'm like where is season seven
everybody knows what EVP is electronic
voice phenomenon yeah they have to like
explain what it is
[Laughter]
yeah so I I don't really know but yeah
so they had to explain too that it's
like oh when it's three scratch marks
that usually means it's demotic because
it's a parody of the Trinity and bloody
black it's all of that
and of course because you can't ever
have a haunting episode that just has
nice friendly ghosts that don't really
do much of anything to you
um
if you have that you always have to have
like an evil ghost and or a demon who is
holding all the other ghosts there
because like I said you can't just have
a Friendly Ghost situation that's not
scary you always have to have somebody
that's like [__] with the other
ghosts and like making them do [__] or
not letting them leave or something like
that so that's what's going on in this
situation too this is a demon and he's
holding the other ghosts hostage for
whatever reason not really sure
so they do a cleansing of course
and a crossover ritual
to what nothing oh you've read something
nice here oh you're a grumpling yeah
he's grumbling I didn't know you ever
think I thought it was because I thought
I remember coming I thought it was a
yeah I said it's a [__] problem
Zach says that might make a cool show
topic ghosts that were nice or helpful
it might it might actually because I
have heard well I really find
interesting stories about ghosts that
um like you know solve their own murders
I think we did a show like with ghosts
at Silver and murders kind of but like
that kind of thing where they like came
like it was your grandma and [__] and
she came back and like told you some
stuff you know what I mean and I'm sure
we could find lots of stories like that
I don't know maybe we should do
something like that
um we did ghosts at solve the remote
murders right yeah a long time ago yeah
I thought we did like that a while back
but um so yes they do the cleansing
thing and the crossover ritual and they
said that worked for a while and
everything was going back to normal
but then and this was pretty weird
because this was something that this is
not exactly something that happened at
our old house but similar
so Chelsea the toddler
um you know she's one or one and a half
or something like that so she can walk
so she wanders off from her mom like
while the mom and the kids are in the
nursery or whatever
and then she kind of goes down the hall
and by the time Amelia notices that
she's gone and then runs out the hall
after her which would look like it was
only like a few seconds
um the baby was out on the balcony even
though the double doors out to the
balcony were still locked like the two
doors were locked on down here and then
there were two locks like way up top
like near the ceiling which obviously a
one-year-old baby could not reach
um so that was a little bit weird so the
baby is out on the [__] balcony and
being like hey I think I'm gonna slip
right between these railings and like
fall to my death yay you know what I
mean it seemed like kind of that
situation so Amelia is implying that she
thinks the demon like opened the door
and then closed them real quick and then
like let the beat or or
um like transported the baby outside
like through the doors or something like
that because it looked like it happened
like super fast
so Amelia obviously is freaking out and
she's like trying to open the doors out
to the balcony but they won't open like
she said it felt like someone was
holding them shut
um and she couldn't get them open she's
like screaming and freaking out because
she's afraid the baby's gonna fall off
the [__] balcony right because the
baby looked like she was really wanting
to fall off the balcony you know what
I'm saying and she said and she was
small enough that she could have fit
through the railings
so finally she gets the door open and
saves the baby
and at this point uh again probably not
surprisingly Amelia is like yeah [__]
this place uh we're done we're leaving
so she calls the paranormal team and
tells them what happened
and she's like not blaming you but your
cleansing didn't do [__] it just made
everything worse yeah so yeah that's it
but that's what I would say
um I was like I know this is an exact
science or anything like that but you
know and I'm not gonna sue you or
nothing but I'm just saying so um so
Chicago's a paranormal team and the
paranormal team says yeah probably you
should move you know what I mean that's
that's bad news
so one of the team actually this was
nice of them but one of the paranormal
team actually let the family like live
with them like stay with them for a
little while until they you know could
find another place so I thought that was
kind of nice
um but while they was like the last
thing that happens is like they go back
this was very Amityville Horror but it's
like they go back to like get all their
[__] out of the house like when they're
moving out and the house it's almost
kind of like gonna give him one big last
performance because like all the [__]
doors start like oh
slamming and [__] like that like by
themselves and uh so there's they're
just like okay we're over this [__] so
then they just get the [__] out and then
it's like very dramatic because it'll
like jump in the car it's like drive go
go get what I mean like you don't know
what's gonna happen so uh they find out
later Amelia said that she asked the
landlord
about the situation
um and she said according to her that
the landlord actually did know about the
[__] I don't know if she meant that he
knew about the kids dying in the
apartment which obviously he would know
because he was landlord or if he knew
about the haunting [__] that was going
on she didn't really specify like which
of those things maybe both things I
don't really know but she said that he
knew about the stuff but then he just
kind of when she complained
she said that he just kind of laughed at
her and said well I don't have to tell
you any of this stuff because you're not
buying the place you're just renting it
so she was like well gee thanks douche
but yeah
but yeah so I so I don't I don't know if
he knew that it was haunted or whatever
so uh they basically moved to another
town like the next town over or
something like that and they said and
they pretty much never came back to the
old town and they don't even ever drive
past that house because it freaks them
out too bad and uh also says Amelia is
still afraid of the dark
she's sleeping with all the lights on
which I can't sleep with the lights on
I'd have to like put a mask over my face
and [__] like that I thought it was a
very basic story it was yeah which uh
because it wasn't really highly
embellished makes me think there might
have been something to it I think they
believed it I don't know what I don't
know exactly what happened wasn't there
just an interesting story
you know they just saw a few
apparitions uh pulled on the doors it
flocked with them a couple times
uh why they were sleeping didn't it
didn't it almost try to suffocate yeah
Calvin yeah he said he felt like it was
suffocating and it spooked him and they
couldn't they couldn't uh get it out of
the house they left
you know pretty common pretty common
Story I mean the weirdest thing to me
like I said was the thing where the baby
somehow got out of the balcony yeah
because that reminded me of the [__]
that happened in our old house
where I got up to go to work in the
morning and I went out in the front room
and the back and the doors the double
doors to the back patio yeah were wide
open so is that you woke me up is that
why I found it too I found it also I
went up there and looked at it no I went
and woke you up well because yeah
because you were still asleep you're
still asleep I was getting up to go to
work
all right so it was only like seven yeah
something in the morning and I walked
out to go out the front door and I was
like what the [__] like the back there's
there were double doors that went back
and it was like right across from the
front door remember that and we never
opened those doors I think the whole
time we lived there which was like 10 11
years I think we only have those doors
open maybe two or three times yeah and
they were
it was open and then deadbolt was still
again the deadbolt was still sticking
out yeah and uh beige was just sitting
there looking at the door like why is
that open yeah she was just sitting
there going
um she knew that [__] wasn't right and
it hadn't been long because the uh the
air conditioner had not the air
conditioning had not escaped so it was
only a few minutes at least it was still
nice and cool in there
yeah it was just I don't know when it
opened it might not have been summer
though huh
I don't remember what time of year it
was it might have been more like fall
yeah I just I can't oh yeah I can't
remember what time of year was I
remember it's kind of windy yeah
but that was the weirdest and that was
the only time that happened with those
doors yeah but it yeah they were just
wide open weird
that was that was during the time when a
bunch of weird stuff was happening
yeah just I found them like that in the
morning and like I said we never opened
those doors and the deadbolt was still
in yeah
so it's like I don't know how that could
have happened and it was weird to me too
that like Beijing seemed to know that
something wasn't right about it because
normally if you open the door she'd be
like oh I can go outside you know what I
mean but she didn't she was just sitting
there like looking at it like dead and
right I don't like it yeah you know what
I mean like she did she didn't go
anywhere and then she kind of yeah then
she kind of turned around and looked at
me and I was like yeah I don't know what
the [__] going on either yeah she
didn't know why it was open yeah so yeah
that was like really creepy I think that
that creeped me out more than anything
yeah I don't know why
because it was I guess because I really
couldn't figure out how that could have
happened on its own yeah you know what I
mean like other the other [__] the other
[__] like oh the TV coming on by itself
and stuff like that I'm like that was
weird but it's like you know they're
drawn remote possibly be an explanation
for that but finding the doors open like
that with the deadbolt in or like you
know the remote flying through the air
[__] like that it's like there really
wasn't any other yeah we weren't there
when it pulled the molding off no yeah
it wasn't there I mean that was just one
big boom It All Happened yeah I just got
told about that afterwards I was at work
when that happened yeah but that was
weird
I know exactly what that was I was like
okay yeah you know what that is
but it didn't it didn't chill me like it
used to it was just like I understand it
because you kind of like knew yeah I
kind of by I'm older now so I kind of
know what it is well and you knew that
it wasn't like an outside yeah entity
yes this early
so it's not gonna you're not gonna be
like oh or anything like that right
Zach says not gonna lie I'm the type to
be ass naked when home alone I just make
sure to have a robot hand
yeah I don't I don't really do that well
not so much no not so much
like if we're just in the bedroom or
something like that yeah but I don't
like usually walking around the house
like that
um let me say oh
Zach says that reminds me the time I
legit got my head stuck in a railing
that's a little one I think that happens
to a lot of kids because you know kids
are like hey look I can fit my head
through here and then they're like oh
[__] I can't get it back out wasn't that
was in um something I just watched
recently oh it was um
that adaptation of that Stephen King
saying Storm of the Century I don't
remember that had like a whole plot well
I did a thing for it for my uh other
channel and I so I just watched it not
too long ago and that had a whole thing
where a girl got her head stuck in the
[__] I don't think I ever did but
there was something that reminded me of
something where a kid
fell off a house and then hit the damn
fence and the spike the fences a bunch
of spikes and it went through him and he
was hanging on it remember that
and they had to cut it to get him off
yeah that's happened more than once yeah
I ran through his head I remember yeah I
remember one guy I don't know if it was
a kid but maybe it was a teenager yeah
it's like a teenager yeah and I thought
he was climbing over a fence like into a
pool area or something something like
that and then like slipped and then he
paled himself and impaled himself he
lived he lived yeah but he was hanging
to that thing for a [__] a long time
yeah calling people help me
yeah that's like that's almost as bad as
that [__] story that you told about
that guy yeah about the guy that got
[__] impaled yeah like almost or his
[__] yeah yeah through a ground guide
rod on the end of a [__] Humvee
that that just makes me I already told
that story though I know but I'm just
saying that makes me cringe like every
time I think about it it's like [__]
hot yeah he came back from the hospitals
fine and just fine and dead I survived
the man
[Laughter]
piece of wrought iron
wrought iron [__] rebar oh thank you
yeah
well that kind of reminds me of and this
is several years ago
um you know I'm always I'm always like
really weirded out by and grossed out by
like beheading
so there was this photo that was making
the rounds many years ago of a dude's
head just like kind of impaled like on
the top of a like a spiky fence right
and it was just like the head there and
for a long time like people thought it
was fake
but it turned out that the story behind
it it was absolutely real uh the story
behind it was that the guy I guess he
had like it was he had done like a
robbery or something like that and he
was running away from the cops and he
was running away like across the
rooftops and he either jumped or fell
off a roof and he landed on this fence
like and it pulled his body like off so
it just left his head hanging there and
like his body down like that yeah and I
was just where'd you see the picture it
was just going around the internet like
years and years ago because I was like I
saw it and I was like [__] and I was
like I thought it was fake but
apparently it's not I remember when I
was a little kid out in Carson
California when I went to Dominguez
Elementary School there was a little
Library just up the block and they would
take us like on a field trips to go walk
up to the library it was back like in
the third grade
and we would look at me and all the
other little boys that go look we would
go get the damn Geographic no reference
they had all the war stuff in it oh okay
I thought you were gonna go looking and
there was a big old reference book on
World War II
and we were just fascinated on this one
section of the war in the Pacific and it
was like photographs from [__] Pele
the island of Pele and stuff where they
they had [__] cut off those Japanese
dudes heads and had them on the [__]
ends of the tanks and guys were walking
around oh yeah I've seen something yeah
yeah [__] Untold [__] bizarre [__]
happened out there
they went crazy and they were head
hunting
both sides were
looking in some of the [__] you know
where guys were pinned down by sniper
fire and these stupid ass valleys and
they'd be there for a week surrounded by
rotten bodies
enough of of dead enemy they're putting
their heads up and [__] and they were
going crazy out there dudes walking
around [__] carrying heads
and it started off because they found
some dude that had been like they had
they found a dude
an American dude who'd been tied to some
bamboo poles and
been emasculated and tortured to death
and that that set all that off and they
had they had uh
orders to destroy the Japanese force on
that island and there's no way to take
any of them prisoner because you had to
bring them on the boat you couldn't
bring him on the boat you had to
continue up those eyelids so basically
it was just a there would take no
prisoners you know either side
you couldn't be captured they'd kill you
and it's just Savage and what strangely
enough Ed Wood was in that that's right
and Ed Wood was wearing women's
underwear during that or so he says so
he says I don't know if it's true he was
wearing broad panties underneath his
uniform that's a scared he didn't care
about getting killed he was scared of
getting wounded because he couldn't
explain it
I mean you can explain it it's just I
don't I don't know if anybody it keeps
me calm back then would have uh no they
wouldn't [__] understand what the
[__] understood the explanation like now
I'd be like all right whatever you do
you but you know hey yeah sure they're
they're comfy Maelstrom says I hope when
I die it's in a way that my picture
isn't spread around yeah I think that's
kind of what we would all want thank you
very much Maelstrom I made it he says I
made it I'm glad you made it I'm glad
you made it but yeah I know it's like
you're just showing up now you want to
watch the beginning of the show yeah
yeah because we were kind of like all
right we mentioned some stuff yeah yeah
um Zach says I still haven't recovered
from the medical show I saw as a kid of
the guy who got a branch up his ass when
he fell out of a tree
I mean
that's the one that I know we make a lot
of jokes about you know people coming in
the emergency room with stuff up their
ass yeah and like that all the funny
stories they tell about how it got there
but that is one thing where it's like
legitimately I would not laugh at that
because that
used to be there used to be a a site
back in the early internet back in the
in the Proto internet back when it was
the Wild West it was called Gore gallery
goregallery.com it probably doesn't
exist anymore and it was just a
dub site for a whole bunch of just
disgusting photographs yeah because you
know people want to think yes it had
Jeffrey Dahmer's pitchers in there it
had a bunch of old murder scenes crime
scene photographs and uh [__] what was
what was it you said you saw because it
reminded me of something I saw on girl
core Gallery what they had on the um no
the head on the fence no there was
something I was gonna
I saw something on Gore gallery that was
relevant and I forgot what it was I went
off into the gore Gallery world trying
to remember what was there tree branch
up the ass no no oh okay
oh yeah
they had a whole segment of um of of
x-rays from hospitals that were uh
[__] foreign objects yeah and it was
the the x-rays of foreign objects of
[__] that [__] people put up their
ass
one of the ones was a damn toy train
like the [__] see what okay was it a
metal one like a metal train from a
train set okay or like a wooden one no
no metal train like like remember what
was it Tycho yeah yeah or no okay who
made those you know it looked like a
yeah 1950s silver [__] boy yeah well
I was wondering because they make those
wooden ones too like you put around your
Christmas tree and [__] so yeah I know
not a locomotive this was like a diesel
train I guess
this
I mean I'll admit that there are some
things that it's like well that looks
like that could go up your butt you know
what I mean but a train is a toy train
is not one of those things yeah it just
shows it shows the X-ray and the outline
of that [__] train
the comments section people just
laughing
ha
and what was the story did he have no
there's no stories there was no story
there's no story to go along with how
that got I don't know how that got up
there back in those days of Gore Gallery
it was just like a photograph baby
comments I was kidnapped and drugged and
somebody just crammed a train at my ass
and then just left yeah the the what do
you call it uh it took a long time for a
photo to download when you looked at it
yeah that's part of the suspense
[Laughter]
and then uh
yeah
wow
but I think I think only the only the uh
the scrapbook or the the what do you
call it
the group of photos it just said this is
these are photographs of uh X-rays of
foreign objects put up in design people
that's it and then just they're probably
about 40 50 photographs are just weird
[__] I don't there was a bunch of them
they were all weird but the train was
the train I remember the train yeah
no live hamsters or anything like that
no fruit like big old [__] big old
[__] um
zucchinis and stuff or well see that's
not I mean it's weird but that's not
that weird pretty big because at least
that's kind of that's vaguely
dick-shaped yeah you're right a train is
not really addiction it was a train
I just remember that one that dude just
he he loved a challenge that guy
he's like I want some sharp edges he's
made up some kind of excuse I bet you I
was walking okay
that's how they are it always starts off
when I was walking or I was up on a
ladder I was on a ladder painting a room
yeah yeah that was the one I heard and I
stripped and I fell and it happened no
next thing I know
I ain't gonna talk about it there was an
HO scale yeah yeah
metal train just like up yeah and uh
yeah and he just fell on it like okay I
said we gotta ride the train
was by looking at them by memory by
looking at the thing it was like
probably about like 10 inches maybe
yeah for everybody that's a braver man
than I you know just like an electric
train set yeah my dad used to have yes
as far as navigated no
um chug up to him I don't know but John
Gora said uh he was working on his train
set and accidentally hit the power and
yeah yeah maybe he was like leaning over
and it was just I was I was I was
building a new [__] train station I
was playing on the track
I was pretending that I was a tunnel
yeah I had my hand inside the tunnel and
the train was coming and I forgot
and it punched right through my jeans
[Laughter]
souped up motor
powerful training
oh my God then I decided so I had like a
really funny mental image of like a dude
like a naked dude like laying on a table
with all the with with his with the
outside of his ass like painted to look
like a train tunnel well I remember
another one I remember another one from
Gore Gallery the shampoo bottle
yeah like I said that's also not weird
because I mean like I said it's weird
but it's not that weird because it's at
least sort of that shape but back in the
night and they're and they're handy like
when you're in the shower you're just
like I wonder back in the 90s back in
the in the late 90s when the internet
was kind of new and you were [__] in
your 20s still you're like no that
didn't happen it happened you know
you're kind of naive right man you'd be
impressed by everything people put on I
can't believe yeah I told you my sister
used to do billing for um
for a GI clinic and she's like people
put all kind of old romance things up
there butts yeah it's crazy and she has
to like the same code like the sheds
there's a code for it for an object yeah
she's like oh what was it okay
Zach says oh the train was coming all
right yeah
yeah I got so
holy [__]
where's that how does this always happen
we're talking about ghosts and then all
of a sudden we're talking about somebody
sticking a train up there now we're
talking about trains and talking and
then gays wanted to come in here with
all this anal train [__] it reminded me
of some other things they were [__]
on the internet one time there was a
whole there was a whole like a little
site where they were where people were
kind of like goofing on people's Pride
on people's day dating apps now they
didn't really weren't apps back they
were acting profiles dating profiles
that they had back then
and one of them was kind of funny it was
just This heavyweight bear type dude
dressed up in a conductor's uniform with
his big trade set looking for another
guy just like him oh yeah but it was
just funny you're not gonna at least
talking about you know he's gonna put
the conductor and the two cheesus and
all these [__] he's using all this
[__] euphemisms for you know [__]
it's [__] funny
but I remember that one is in there did
he use the phrase running a train just
anything yeah it was kinky but you
looked at the dude and you would you
didn't you wouldn't like suspected you
wouldn't
he was not stereotypically gay that's
what I was thinking of especially back
in the days you know what I mean it just
looked like some dude I wonder if he
ever found his soulmate he's looking for
another dude I hope he found somebody
that was into the exact same [__] and
they were just like the big old train
set he was probably about 50 then Trane
said they were sick maybe maybe one of
them was the guy that had the train
stuck up his ass
open up here comes the two
checks instead of in your mouth I
haven't seen that Hobby in a long time
that's the old school hobby building
those [__] train sets my dad my dad
used to do that he had a hole like in
the garage he had like this whole like
thing where he built all that and there
used to be so much space it did yeah it
took up like most of their garage it was
cool though I did like to go in there
and look at it but he um in Daytona
where I grew up there used to be a big
toy store it was like two stories and it
was called done toys
and the Upper Floor was all train stuff
so it had like you could so every now
and then like we'd go there and like buy
little trees and little post offices and
[__] like that we like put them all in
the [__] it was pretty cool actually
but uh but yeah so I don't know whatever
happened to that uh Ben said have you
ever heard that Derek and clavskit were
the guys masturbating this train set and
this mother bus him I have not actually
no
Zach said I found a legit cute grinder
profile once of a guy who said he made
too many cookies and invited people over
to eat them
that's so wholesome I I love it where
they well wait a minute though like were
they poisoned probably I'm cynical I'm
just always kind of like if somebody
says that oh my God I made so many
cookies somebody could come over and
help me eat these I'm like they're
either Edibles or they have [__]
arsenic in them or some [__] like that
I'm not going over there and eating the
cookies Tom made cookies again today
yeah
again
[Laughter]
God damn it I [__] lowered the
temperature down to 350 and only cooked
it for 10 minutes and they were still
there perfectly gooey on the top they're
still burned on the bottom but I'll tell
you what I ate one and it's still
delicious peanut butter cookies they
didn't do the oatmeal didn't do that
I don't know maybe there's something
about peanut butter that makes it burn
quicker on that type of but the top
doesn't burn no just the bottom yeah now
you put what I did is I took them I took
a uh you can you can take them and uh go
over to the sink and get a steak knife
and just scrape some of the burnt like
you would toast it just comes right off
well yeah so I can eat them anyway
pissed me off though
they're still good though burned up
twice in a row don't worry about it
I'm gonna [__] change the temperature
again I'm gonna go down I'm gonna go to
like
325 and then only cook them for like
seven minutes or eight minutes see what
happens
I wonder if a different cookie sheet
yeah I think it has to do that cookie
sheet it might be yeah that might be
that cookie sheet is not because it
seems like it's not cooking them evenly
and I'm not really sure why that is so
it's scorching them
yeah but just on the bottom just on the
bottom it's really like the top looks
perfect yeah it's real thin scorched
area on the bottom I don't know if you
can't understand it it's weird
Zach says there are legit some foods
that are really good when slightly burnt
and I have no idea why yeah well I mean
isn't there that whole burnt tips thing
yeah the meat you know what I mean are
you getting um
yeah I can tell he's over there going on
yeah you know what I mean we're talking
too much about food talking too much
about food again yeah all right so I
guess we'll wrap it up since we're done
talking about the haunting episode
anyways so uh so yeah so hopefully you
guys enjoyed the show on the Wednesday
night show the main show we're going to
be doing killer moms we're gonna be
talking about Susan Smith and Andrea
Yates
both of whom drowned their children
they're under different circumstances
okay but uh so yeah so I've been
watching uh documentaries about these
two for the last couple days so uh so
yeah so that's what we're going to be
talking about on Wednesday night so have
yourselves a good day tomorrow good rest
of your evening tonight and we'll see
you guys again on Wednesday night good
night